marvel rigole 0 le trailer de far from
home vient de sortir et nous amène déjà
sur du post endgame je vous propose
d'analyser le trailer est théorisé
dessus car bon sens il y a des choses à
dire
néanmoins je préfère vous mettre en
garde far from home est une suite qui se
passe peu de temps après endgame et donc
ne regardez pas cette vidéo s'il ne
voulait pas être spoilé vous êtes
prévenus pour ceux qui l'ont vu merci à
ceux qui laisseront un pouce bleus c'est
très important
allez commençons je ne vais pas vous
proposer une analyse plan par plan car
je pense que cela n'aurait aucun intérêt
rentrons plutôt dans le vif du sujet
avec les thématiques proposées par le
film ce que je trouve incroyable avec ce
trailer c'est que j'ai une vidéo qui
doit sortir cette semaine qu'ils
traitent justement des réalités
alternatives et du voyage dans le temps
de nos chers avengers et du coup far
from home est en plein dedans
première chose frappante spider man a du
mal à tourner la page par rapport à tony
stark
ce dernier était comme son mentor et si
tony l'avait pris sous son aile
c'est qu'il en valait la peine et avait
décelé le potentiel du jeune héros nous
parlons quand même d'iron man le héros
qui prévoyait tout et se préparer à la
menace thanos depuis des années
spider man est encore plus important
qu'on le pense happy hogan le confirme
de lui même nous pouvons faire le
rapprochement par rapport à nick fury
ce n'est pas spécialement montré dans
les films mais cela a été déclaré nick
fury possédait deux avengers principaux
de pilier sur lequel ils pouvaient se
reposer
captain marvel et tony stark c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il appela captain
marvel dans une infinité houara stark
étant injoignable et coincé sur titan
personne ne savait où il était fiori
n'avait plus d'autre choix que de faire
appel à carole site owni avait pris pour
ce dos aux élèves l'homme araignée
il est évident que nick fury allait se
tourner vers lui pour qu'il remplace
iron man et le forme afin de devenir un
leader et un héros très puissant peter
parker est jeune et va être le héros
nous montrant la plus grande courbe
d'évolution dans le mc eu
parlons maintenant du multivers
effectivement et les mentionner dans le
film que
monsieur bec alias mystérieux
deviendrait de la terre mais pas celle
que nous connaissons soit une réalité
alternative
nick fury affirme même que cela est dû à
l'effacement entre guillemets évidemment
il parle du snap est dit que le snapo
récréer une faille mais cela reste assez
flou priori faisait partie des victimes
du snap de thanos et n'a donc pas connu
les événements d'un game il n'est donc
pas de source sûre pour affirmer
pourquoi il ya d'autres réalités
je vous en parle justement dans ma
prochaine vidéo qui devrait sortir aux
alentours de mercredi je ne vais pas
raconter tout ce qu'il ya dedans mais je
peux parler rapidement des réalités
créées cela reste personnelle mais
d'après moi les avengers par le biais de
leurs actions dans le passé ont créé 5
réalité alternative
ce n'est pas une simple action qui a
modifié le cours de l'histoire mais
l'ensemble de plusieurs actions
effectuées à une période précise
prenons l'exemple de 2012 où tony et
antoine ont permis à lockheed s'échapper
avec le tesseract ou encore captain qui
se fait passer pour un membre d'hydra
tout ça ne fait pas partie de l'histoire
originale à la base et crée donc une
nouvelle branche où les membres d'hydra
n'auront pas le sceptre et olot qui n'y
aura pas se faire juger sur as garde et
possédera le tesseract bref j'espère que
vous comprenez l'idée sinon je vous
donne rendez-vous dans ma prochaine
vidéo
les frères russo ont affirmé en
interview que steve avait bel et bien
créé une réalité alternative suite aux
évènements d'un game où il souhaitait
justement retrouver peggy dans le passé
pour moi je pense que les avengers
aurait créé une réalité alternative en
1945 par le biais de steve en 1970 en
2012 2013 et enfin 2014
il est vrai que nous le soupçonnions pas
au début mais ngame et far from home
signe la fin de la phase 3 est donc le
début de la phase 4 qui va réellement
aller beaucoup plus loin en termes
cosmique dimension et donc réalités
réalités qui ont été introduits par ce
dernier film il est temps maintenant de
passer à mystérieux le plus gros mystère
de ce nouveau film marvel
dans les thrillers mystérieux alias
quand un bec vient sauver la réalité de
nos chers à dodger ce quart des monstres
élémentaire viennent mettre un sacré
bazar
je ne m'attarderai pas spécialement sur
ces monstres élémentaire car il semble
très différent des comics ou spider man
durant son épopée affronte
successivement un homme avec des
pouvoirs en rapport avec l'eau un autre
en rapport avec le sable d'ailleurs se
pourrait-il que cette créature se réfère
à l'homme sable c'est tout à fait
possible ou encore le mountain man soit
magma en fusion en gros je pense
d'ailleurs que les normes créatures que
nous voyons à la fin pourrait être la
réunification des trois éléments pour ne
former plus qu'un seul monstre doux sa
grandeur et sa puissance il semblerait
que ces trois ennemis ne soit considérée
que comme de simples monstre dans far
from est justement par rapport à bec
il ya quelque chose d'assez flou car
dans les comics mystérieux est un vilain
de spider man et donc il ya un
rapprochement à faire nous sommes
habitués depuis les derniers marvel à
avoir des gros ennemis avec des bagram
conséquent et non de simples monstre qui
veulent tout détruire bec cache quelque
chose
nous sommes quand même sur un film
signant la fin de la phase iii
mystérieux est connu pour ses capacités
d'illusionniste de manipulateur et
possède un but précis à la base faire
passer spider man pour le bas de gamme
effectivement nous sommes dans le mc u
et le personnage aura sa propre
personnalité dues au film mais nous
parlons tout de même d'un méchant des
comics ce qui peut nous faire douter
c'est dû au fait qu'il possède de réels
pouvoirs dans le trailer ou encore que
les acteurs aient déclaré qu'il était
bien un gentil dans le film je pense
personnellement que marvel essaye de
nous refaire la même entourloupe qu'avec
les trailer de captain marvel par
rapport aux skrull qu'il faisait passer
pour les méchants
il se peut que mystérieux soit un gentil
durant le film far from home mais nous
dévoilera sa véritable identité et les
films suivants j'aimerais justement
revenir sur les passages au mystérieux
parle avec peter ce dernier lui demande
clairement ce qu'ils souhaitent ou lui
affirme encore qu'il n'est peut-être pas
prêt mais que lui possède des
responsabilités je sens une certaine
manipulation dans le personnage car
peter souhaite juste passer des vacances
avec mj à la base et ne se sent pas à la
hauteur
beck se rapproche de spider man et
essaye d'en savoir plus sur lui ce n'est
pas anodin
ce qui est fascinant c'est que vu que le
multivers semble être amenées pour ce
film
nous ne savons pas ce qu'il s'est passé
sur la réalité de bec il est fort
possible que ce soit ce dernier qui
aurait amené les monstres élémentaire
dans la réalité de spider man pour mieux
la voir par derrière ou encore que le
spider man de la réalité de mystérieux
lui ait fait quelque chose de mal et il
est fortement possible que le quand un
bec de la réalité que nous connaissons
soit quelqu'un ans sans pouvoir
bref une infinité de possibilités
peuvent arriver mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que mystérieux cache réellement
quelque chose il se peut que mystérieux
viennent de l'une des cinq réalité que
je vous ai proposé tout à l'heure mais
il est également possible qu'ils
viennent d'une autre réalité qui n'a pas
été spécialement montré dans une game
bref vous avez compris l'idée en tout
cas comme je vous l'affirmé dans mes
précédentes vidéos d'ailleurs n'hésitez
pas à aller les voir spider man va avoir
de lourdes responsabilités et grandir
énormément de choses reposent sur lui
maintenant il va devoir prendre le rôle
de tony stark far from home est le
dernier film de la phase iii et ce n'est
pas un hasard si il est orienté autour
de spider man personnellement je ne sais
pas trop ce que la scène post générique
nous tease rats mais ce sera forcément
quelque chose de puissant pour
l'intrigué total de la phase 4 et j'ai
hâte de savoir fact intéressant aussi
c'est que doctor strange 2 l'un des
premiers films de la face qu'à arriver
après spider man en 2021 traitera
presque obligatoirement des dimensions
ou autre réalité avec son ennemi
nightmare bref du très très lourd arrive
et va falloir s'accrocher
je ne pense pas qu'on soit réellement
prêt j'espère en tout cas que cette
vidéo vous aura plu
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à lâcher
votre plus gros pouce bleus et à vous
abonner
vous pouvez me suivre sur twitter où je
vous fais actuellement gagner des
figurines pop thanos nuls à de nouvelles
vidéos arrivent dans la semaine bref
écoutez cet argot rock merci de m'avoir
suivi et que le liner soit avec vous
[Musique]